I came to trust my intuition of course
with a little bit of trial and error
framing the process and I think it's one
of the strongest and richest creative
force except it's very sad to see around
us mostly now system of education that
we shrivel that force we say to a kid
don't think of you by yourself with the
book listen to your teacher do what the
adult says and well yes there were some
truths there but I think the best way to
open the door to intuition for a child
is to put them in front of a creative
problem you know I don't know a little
origami or building something and then
first let them do what they feel at them
we lay on their intuition and then if
they go in a completely wrong direction
they themself will stop and turn to
adult for help you know so it's a very
delicate thing to teach to bring
intuition to a child or to anybody for
that matter but mostly child they're so
sensitive about being forced to do and
to think a certain way so my my proposal
is to not open the door and you know and
propolis the kids forward but to open
the door tiny bit and have the kid
callosity keep moving that door that was
ajar now it's full and then they're
going to discover they're gonna explore
with their own way of thinking their own
intuition and improvisation and then yes
the adult is there to make sure there is
no accident you know
you